anthony gratacos bienvenus merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl ce matin
alors gérald darmanin l'avait promis 1
il a annoncé officiellement hier engagé
la procédure de dissolution du groupe
génération identitaire à des réactions
se sont fait entendre comme celle de
florian philippot regarder puis vous
réagi sans suite tous les commentateurs
le savent mais aucun ne le dira darmanin
lance la dissolution de génération
identitaire uniquement pour se racheter
auprès des cadres lrm furieux qu'il ait
dit à marine le pen sur france 2 l'autre
soir qu'elle était trop molle minable
politique politicienne alors un moyen
pour le ministre de l'intérieur de se
rattraper après ces propos lors du débat
avec marine le pen à ce que vous vous
rejoignez ses propos ce constat non je
ne rejoins pas le constat de florian
philippot cette association est dénoncée
depuis longtemps par les militants
antiracistes et au fond c'est une bonne
décision que cette dissolution alors une
bonne décision je parlais de marine le
pen a considéré par christophe castaner
comme ennemis de la république est ce
que c'est le cas pour vous marine le pen
n'est pas une ennemie de la république
c'est une opposante politique je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ses idées
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce qu'elle
défend mais elle a le droit d'exister
elle a le droit de le défendre
si elles étaient hors la loi le
rassemblement national n'existerait pas
alors la dissolution de génération
identitaire une bonne chose pour vous
venez de le dire la question d'identité
elle s'est aussi des bas à gauche art la
semaine dernière un débat était organisé
par génération point s et la députée
danielle obodo a défendu le droit je
cite pour les personnes racisées de
s'auto-organiser qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de ce type de vision
je crois effectivement la gauche est
traversée par des débats sur ces
questions d'identité mais au fond je
crois que nous avons tous arrivés au
même objectif l'objectif de la gauche
c'est l'émancipation humaine
simplement on n'a pas forcément pris les
mêmes chemins nous à la gauche
républicaine et socialiste on défend
l'universalisme la nécessité d'une
république forte et de services publics
forts qui permettent la cohésion
nationale et l'égalité entre les
citoyens et pas la différenciation ce
sont des chemins qui peuvent nous
séparer à gauche mais il y à un débat et
il est nécessaire d'y participer
c'est à dire que pour vous la question
du racialisme c'est pas un bon cap à
prendre non puisque c'est un un cap
différentialiste donc c'est un cap qui
sépare forcément les gens nous ce que
l'on vous ce que nous voulons c'est des
mesures qui permettent de les rapprocher
et de faire nation ensemble non de
reconnaître on ne reconnaît pas de
communauté la seule communauté qu'on
reconnaît à la gauche républicaine et
socialistes c'est la république alors le
texte de loi séparatisme a été voté
samedi à l'assemblée nationale en pleine
polémique avec la ville de trappes un
certain que certains jugeaient aux mains
des islamistes le maire ali rabais
aurait distribué dans un lycée un tract
attaquant le professeur qui avait
dénoncé en souvenir la situation dans la
commune sa suite si tu es là encore des
réactions regarder michel blanc caire
doit porter plainte contre le maire de
trappes entrer dans un établissement
sans autorisation est un délit puni par
l'article 431 22 du code pénal la
république doit être intraitable contre
les alliés de l'islamisme et protéger
les enseignants qui résistent solidarité
avec ali rabais qui fait face à des
menaces glaçante
il serait grand temps que cesse
l'emballement médiatique et politique et
que chacun s'en tiennent à la vérité et
au fait et votre avis jean michel
blanquer rs qu'il doit porter contre le
maire de trappes ou ou au contraire vous
vous apportez votre soutien à ali rabais
évidemment notre soutien à lire abbey
l'emballement médiatique qu'on a connus
sur la sphère de trappes
la semaine dernière nous mais quand même
dans une situation terrible
aujourd'hui il y à un enseignant qui est
menacée et un maire un élu de la
république qui est menacé c'est
intolérable
et c'est intolérable parce que on est
dans une situation où la société est
inflammable est extrêmement divisé et
plutôt que de chercher à apaiser la
société on utilise des événements tels
que celui ci pour alimenter des
polémiques qui ne mènent à rien parce
que aucune solution
on se demande s'il faut porter plainte
contre l'enseignant soutenir ou palmer
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour calmer la situation
et justement qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
vous pour calmer la situation
mais il faut que l'état reprenne son
rôle
il faut arrêter de casser les services
publics il faut arrêter fermé des
tribunaux des écoles des centres des
impôts
il faut arrêter de diminuer la présence
de la poste dans les zones rurales
il faut arrêter de baisser les budgets
il faut arrêter de supprimer des
fonctionnaires
parce que c'est ça qui crée aujourd'hui
des inégalités sur le territoire qui
fait penser à des pans entiers de la
sentiers de la société qu'elle est
séparée du reste de la communauté
nationale
il faut réinvestir nos territoires et il
faut réparer l'état qui est gravement
blessée par les politiques d'austérité
qui ont été menées ces vingt dernières
années par tous les gouvernements qui se
sont succédé ont changé de couleur mais
qu'ont mené la même politique de
destruction des services publics avec un
concours lépine de la loi la plus
antisociale possible c'est à ça qu'il
faut mettre un terme
il faut changer de cap et je suis pas
sûr que ce sera ce gouvernement qu'il le
fera et contraires concernant la loi sur
le séparatisme
certains notamment à droite disent que
le problème de l'islamisme n'a pas été
assez nommé et que finalement c'est un
peu toutes les religions qui sont
concernés du coup et qui sont montrés du
doigt vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on voit bien que la droite qui est qui a
un peu disparu depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et dont la surenchère
comme on voit bien que cette loi est une
loi électorale dont le processus a été
accéléré suite à l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit alors que les dispositions qui
sont proposés dans cette loi un peu
fourre-tout sont soit inapplicable soit
existent déjà dans le droit
mais encore une fois la question qui est
posée c'est celle des moyens
un exemple concret quand on cherche à
contrôler l'enseignement à domicile pour
pouvoir le faire il faut du personnel à
l'éducation nationale
quand on supprime des fonctionnaires à
l'éducation nationale on empêche ce
genre de contrôles mais il faut que
l'état assume son rôle de contrôle et
toutes les dispositions qui peuvent être
prises n'ont aucune conséquence s'il n'y
a pas de moyens qui sont mis derrière
donc la question qui est réellement
posée c'est celle des moyens que veut se
donner l'état pour lutter contre la
radicalisation ou des uns ou des autres
parce que la radicalisation elle est
multiple je crois pas que cette loi vise
une religion en particulier il y a dans
l'islam
une forme de radicalisation qu'on
connaît aussi chez les catholiques
on a tous vu ces camps de jeunes
catholiques intégristes qui se tiennent
n'était comme les écoles judaïque hors
contrat donc cette loi tente de répondre
à un problème sans s'en donner les
moyens et le parti veut arriver à un
objectif qu'est la cohésion nationale
s'en remettre l'état au coeur des
politiques publiques
alors que votre regard maintenant
concernant la situation sanitaire
peut-être plus précisément la stratégie
vaccinale
le chef de l'état il s'est exprimé hier
dans les colonnes du jdd on l'a vu dans
cette édition notamment il appelle à une
stratégie mondiale pour finalement
vacciner massivement les populations
c'est comme ça que la france va pouvoir
s'en tirer et l'europe c'est avec une
stratégie mondiale selon vous mais pour
le coup emmanuel macron met le doigt sur
un point qui est très important c'est
que la france peut pas dresser des murs
autour de ses frontières
cette pandémie et mondial la réponse à
cette pandémie doit être mondiale si on
se limite à la vaccination des pays
occidentaux et de l'asie on va on va
être très limité en termes des changes
et de voyages aujourd'hui cette pandémie
a des conséquences économiques terribles
et sociale encore plus terribles sur
notre pays
si on ne s'intéresse pas à la
vaccination des pays les plus pauvres et
les plus en difficulté si on n'accélère
pas la production des vaccins
ça ne règlera pas la situation chez nous
en plus emmanuel macron en a parlé le
risque de d'augmentation de ces variants
de mutation du virus
si ils continuent de circuler et de plus
en plus grands et donc protéger les
autres c'est aussi nous protéger nous
mêmes le monde l'a déjà fait l'a fait
une fois quand en 1958 l'urss a proposé
à l'om est-ce de lutter contre la
variole le monde a mis 13 en vacciner
massivement et à se battre pour
supprimer la variole et ça a permis en
1982 déclarer la disparition de la
variole du monde
je pense qu'il faut s'en inspirer et
qu'il faut suivre le même chemin si on
veut s'en sortir parce qu'on s'en
sortira pas tout seul peut-être une
dernière question en quelques mots il
nous reste quelques secondes côté
économique
bruxelles attend que le plan de relance
de 750 milliards d'euros soit adopté par
les parlements nationaux ce plan de
relance vous l'approuvez vous
il faudrait trouver où se trouve la
relance dans ce plan en fait parce que
il faut donner quand même quelques
chiffres la france va avoir 40 milliards
de la part de l'union européenne pour
mettre en place un plan de 100 milliards
la perte de revenus d'activité en 2020
c'est 200 milliards d'euros le prêt
garanti par l'état le chiffre que j'ai
là du mois de novembre ces 130 milliards
d'euros le coût du chômage partiel
estimé pour 2021 ces 10 milliards
d'euros
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec 100 milliards
qu'est-ce qu'on relance pas grand chose
c'est comme vous dire de mettre du
whisky dans le réservoir à essence de
votre véhicule parce qu'il est à sec
ça vous fera pas avancer ça va même
peut-être cassé le moteur est en échange
de des miettes
on veut bien nous jeter on nous demande
de faire des réformes structurelles sur
les retraites entre autres le projet de
réforme des retraites du gouvernement on
nous connaît
c'est une opération perdante pour tout
le monde et donc ce qu'on va nous donner
d'une main on va nous demander de rendre
de l'autre
donc non je ne crois pas que ce plan
soit une bonne chose merci à ou anthony
gratacos d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl je le
rappelle vous êtes secrétaire général de
la gauche républicaine et socialiste